I think that the Iraq war has had a
catastrophic impact on America's image
around the world if you talk to ordinary
citizens even in countries whose
government supported the Iraq war like
the United Kingdom their trust and
respect for the actions of the US
government and for American foreign
policy it you know has reached a
historical low and they basically are
not willing to give the u.s. the benefit
of the doubt any more than anything the
idea of American leadership on big
global issues certainly but with this
administration is kind of unthinkable
I'm not sure how how long lasting that
is I think some of that can change with
the new administration if there's an
Obama or Clinton or even and McCain
presidency you know people are
instinctively going to rebalance
everything that decides in the same way
that they do with with a George Bush
administration but I do think that
underlying that there is a bigger
difference between now and the past
which is the fact that the Cold War has
ended and Europeans no longer depend on
the u.s. to protect them in the way that
they did during the Cold War and I think
that that was a big structural change
which is much more important than the
Iraq war and maybe what happened over
the Iraq war was a reflection of the
fact that Europeans could afford not to
some European governments could afford
not to back the u.s. because they didn't
need American protection the way they
did
I think there are obsessive watches of
the American election have looked all
the twists and turns in the different
primaries and the battle between Hillary
and Obama it's only which has completely
energized lots of Europeans and I think
it's one of the things which will lead
to a big change in the way that the u.s.
is perceived that the genius that the
American political system has to
reinvent America and to give itself a
second chance by casting one group of
people out and having an entirely new
cast of people who are in charge of the
country if there's a conservative
government in Britain I think they will
initially be an attempt to move further
away from the European mainstream than
the Blair and brown governments have
been in recent years there's a lot of
ideological skepticism about the
European project in the Conservative
Party but I think that I'm not sure how
long this this policy will will last or
how far they can take it in a way as all
governments when they come into power
have a pretty rude awakening when they
start dealing with this using the real
world and we saw it very clearly with
george bush where if you look at the you
know the famous article in foreign
affairs by condoleezza rice which talked
about a humble american foreign policy
not getting entangled in in adventures
abroad and then what happened after
September the eleventh it was like night
and day and I think we might very well
find that the same thing happens with
with a Conservative government in the UK
because there is quite frankly no future
for british foreign policy outside of
the european context and for most of the
things that britain wants to do in the
world that the most effective way to do
it is going to be by working with it
with European partners and having a
strong relationship with the US but
there is it I mean there aren't that
many alternatives available for Britain